what is the number one item that one
needs to rock the ever so important
fashionista movement of Sandler Court I
need it from the horse's mouth you want
to know how I do it in the morning so I
go into my closet I I I got a bunch of
t-shirts and shorts kind of they're all
the same but I mean uh I I usually go I
usually go t-shirt first I don't know
which one I just want to cover that
quickly
I'm like what the hell grab anything
then I go with shorts and I throw them
on sometimes they'll be slightly too
tight I go let me take those off and get
the AAA shorts why don't you just have
it like small medium large sections oh
the mediums would be thrown away
immediately